on évoque à présent le sort des enfants
de djihadistes retenu dans le nord-est
de la syrie qui inquiète plusieurs ong
ont lancé aujourd'hui à paris un nouveau
cri d'alarmé des humanitaires qui parle
de danger de mort pour ses enfants le
gouvernement français a soutenu le
rapatriement des mineurs mais dans les
faits est la réalité est tout autre
katia technique
le 15 février plusieurs ong dont la
ligue des droits de l'homme amnesty
international ou l'unicef ont organisé
une conférence de presse pour évoquer le
destin des deux cents enfants français
détenus dans des camps syrie il plaide
pour le rapatriement rapide de ces
petits en souffrance parfois orphelins
dans le nord-est de la syrie près des
frontières turques irakienne ils
croupissent dans les camps de roger ii à
lol depuis des années ils vivent dans
des tentes soumis à des températures
extrêmes -10 l'hiver plus de 40 en été
ils n'ont en outre ni accès à la santé
nih à l'école et les français ignorent
pour la plupart leur triste sort
qualifié d'infamie par les ong présentes
leur mère ont fait le choix de rallier
l'état islamique ils font pour cela
l'objet de mandats d'arrêt
internationaux qui ne sont donc pas
exécutée or ni l'irak ni la syrie ne
sont atteints les juger selon le droit
français parce que d'une part la région
syrienne dur ou java n'est pas reconnu
par la france et de l'autre le fait que
l'irak apic la peine de mort rend tout
transfert pour poursuite illégale selon
un traité international
mais la france elle pourrait traduire
ces femmes en justice quoi qu'il en soit
à ses enfants dont certains sont nés
dans les camps ne peuvent être tenus
responsables des crimes commis par leurs
parents en refusant leur retour la
france entre en violation des
conventions internationales qu'il a
signées qui impose de respecter
l'intérêt souverain de l'enfant et
d'autres pays on te fait le choix du
rapatriement ainsi en 2021 plus de 330
femmes des enfants étrangers ont été
reconduits dans leurs pays respectifs
mais parmi eux signé que sept français
interrogés le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian se dit
toujours ouvert à des rapatriements au
cas par cas mais lesquels pour les
enfants nous continuerons pour les
mineurs isolés les orphelins pour ceux
dont la mère accepte le départ et en
menant à chaque fois des opérations
extrêmement dangereuse dans une zone
toujours en guerre des propos étonnants
alors que la dernière a patrie mans l'ue
en janvier 2021 et qu'il reste deux
cents enfants a ramené parce qu'on nous
assène que ce soit la télévision devant
la cour européenne que ces opérations
sont extrêmement dangereux de l'univers
français sont quand même pas là pour
risquer leurs vies soient pas évidemment
que non sachez le ce n'est d'envoi que
pour les français c'est quand même
exceptionnel parce que deux en plus la
france six hommes elles six hommes et
six notes parce qu'elle ne supporte pas
l'idée de rapatrier des enfants avec
leur mère donc on ne supporte pas l'idée
de respecter les conventions en
prénationale
conséquence de cette inaction une
française de 28 ans est morte faute de
soins dans le camp de rage le 14
décembre dernier elle a derrière elle
une petite orpheline de six ans que la
france à ce jour semblent avoir oublié
le président français est il été
influencé par un sondage hawks a paru en
février 2019 qui s'est tu que 67 % des
français interrogés étaient opposés au
retour en france des enfants de
djihadistes depuis deux tribunes de
personnalités de parlementaires ont
tenté de sensibiliser à la cause de ses
enfants selon l'avocat patrick baudouin
président d'honneur de la ldh
aucun argument uma ou sécuritaire ne
justifie le refus de rapatriement je
pense que la prise de position
le blocage absolu vient de l'hélice
quand on aborde les ministères sert de
jean yvesledrian suit la ligne d'une
façon d'ailleurs c'est scandaleux
quand ils minimisent complètement la
dureté des conditions de détention de
ces enfants mais quand on interroge en
revente les entourages les directeurs de
cabinet les conseillers de divers
ministères en parler du quai d'orsay et
du ministère de la justice il est
certain qu'il y a au fond de ces
personnes une évolution très notable est
le sentiment que louis il faut les
rapatrier où il faudra les payer et
mieux vaudrait sans doute maintenant que
plus tard plusieurs instances ont été
saisis dont la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et les ong
associations espèrent que ce sujet sera
mis en lumière durant la campagne
présidentielle